the death toll continues to rise after
catastrophic flooding swept through
Southeast Texas the remnants of tropical
storm Imelda are being felt in North
Texas and Oklahoma the storm dumped more
than 40 inches of rain in some areas
that are still recovering from the
devastation left by hurricane Harvey two
years ago Mireya Villarreal is in Winnie
Texas Maria good morning well good
morning you know five deaths so far have
been linked to imelda including a 47
year old that was found in a car that
was submerged in these floodwaters so
the good news is some of this water is
starting to recede the road right next
to me this was impassable a few days ago
and now things are getting better but
there is still a lot of floodwaters as
you can see here in people's front yards
and inside their homes officials are
hoping over the next few days that some
of this water will receive even more
allowing them to get a better count of
how many homes businesses cars have been
flooded out by this massive storm
floodwaters sweeping over entire
neighborhoods in Houston are forcing
homeowners to still keep their distance
major highways across Southeast Texas
filled with water leaving drivers to
navigate through treacherous conditions
over the last few days Harris County
officials say hundreds of people were
rescued from their homes when a Bayou
near Huffman became swollen with
floodwater
rescue crews continued to monitor those
areas as conditions improve strong
currents ripped barges loose on the San
Jacinto River and pushed them into
multiple bridge columns forcing the
shutdown of a major freeway until divers
can inspect the damage there is no
pollution or breaches within those
barges and those barges are being moved
mountains of soggy mattresses are the
latest lawn ornaments in Beaumont as the
cleanup begins an immense EO Gomez says
he had roughly a foot of water in his
house literally everything's wet the
water came in very quickly so we didn't
have time to salvage many items 25 miles
west and whinny
people were still being rescued from
their homes Friday this is the second
time in two years we've gone through
this total loss of everything
water is invading every part of Dennis
nations home is this worse than what it
was like two years ago
it is it is from an emotional standpoint
because you we went through it and we we
got through it
he plans to clean up the house but he's
still not sure he'll ever move back in
things are getting better they're just
getting worse it's heartbreaking
officials are worried the death toll
could climb as the waters start to
recede there is a flood warning still in
place in this area and also there is a
curfew in place here in Winnie the
sheriff tells me he wants to make sure
there is no looting in this area
especially because people still can't
get back into their homes Michelle
Maria thank you so much I and so many of
those areas never got back to normal
after what happened a couple of years
ago the homes the area and then now now
this trying to figure out what to do
next
thank you meteorologist Jeff bear Adelie
is here with the latest on what's left
of imelda and the rest of the nation's
weather Jeff good morning good morning
Michelle and good morning everyone so
we're looking at a large map of how much
rain fell during a meld up and wherever
you see the white that's about 20 to 30
inches of rain so it extends from
Houston all the way to the border of
Louisiana and Texas this is immense to
give you some perspective it's the size
of Connecticut and Massachusetts
combined now I called dr. Kerry Emanuel
at MIT he's an atmospheric scientist
that studies these type of events he
says the probability of event like this
happening back in the 1980s and 1990s
was one in 700 but now because of a
warmer climate and climate change it is
a 1 in 100 year event so climate change
is making these types of events more
extreme events
more common so ml does moisture is
moving northward as it does so it's
moving into air temperatures in the 70s
and 80s today em that's colliding with
an invasion of winter across the Rockies
temperatures in the 30s that collision
causing a lot of showers and
thunderstorms in severe weather later
today in Kansas into Missouri also into
Iowa tennis ball-sized hail wind gusts
up to around 70 miles an hour so watch
out for that now because a melda's
moisture is kind of part of this system
what does he about double the amount of
rainfall we otherwise would have a swath
around Kansas City Quincy Des Moines
Chicago could see two to five or six
inches of rain watch out for flash
flooding the rest of the country guys
looking pretty good in fact the first
day of autumn is on Monday enjoy the
rest of your weekend and our transition
to autumn last official weekend of
summer Jeff thank you very much